comment sensibiliser les jeunes à la
problématique de développement durable
c'est pour répondre à cette question que
l'académie de la Réunion a mis en place
un label académique récompensant les
établissements scolaires collège ou
lycée qui s'inscrivent dans une démarche
éco durable c'est ainsi que plusieurs
établissements ont été évalués selon des
critères définis par une charte les
élèves et l'équipe éducatives se sont
retrouvés en cette semaine de
développement durable dans l'enceinte de
l'amphithéâtre commerçan pour une remise
de diplômes et de trophées
grand nombre de personnels
très très grand nombre d'élèves il y a
des échos délégués dans toutes les
classes avec des réunions régulières on
leur donne la parole et on va voir où il
y a trois grands axes dans le projet et
les élèves sont vraiment très très
impliqués et c'est eux qui sont en force
de proposition trois niveaux
d'implication été retenus pour décerner
les récompenses ainsi le collège des
aigrettes a atteint l'excellence
c'est-à-dire le niveau 3 avec un projet
intitulé vague verte donc ça faisait
partie d'une vraie démarche de projet et
à partir de l'enquête qu'on avait menée
était arrivé deux objectifs qui étaient
qui étaient forts le premier c'était de
trier les déchets et le deuxième c'était
de végétaliser l'espace et surtout
d'améliorer le cadre de vie j'aime bien
le projet vague verte parce qu'on
apprend des choses différemment
qu'en classe parce que en classe il nous
apprend les bases et que
au projet vague verte on apprend les non
latins on apprend des arbres on apprend
les noms scientifiques et ça c'est
qui feront que ben on verra la bataille
le plan durable tous ensemble et c'est
le sens donc de l'engagement du conseil
départemental que d'être auprès des
collèges pour que cette démarche
citoyenne soit démultipliée et soit
porteuse d'avenir pour la rue parmi les
autres collèges récompensés on retrouve
entre autres le collège Jean desme
Beauséjour de canon Hubert de lit
l'amiral Beauvais Guy Moquet 3 mars ou
encore point de des châteaux rendez-vous
l'année prochaine pour décerner de
nouveaux prix